he
so when you get to the end of the alley
right onto poinsettia left onto Beverly
how can I help there's just there's no
map on here look at this in 1,000 ft
your destination will be on the right in
1,000 ft I don't know what that looks
like well we're screwed now yeah this is
where ways would have come in handy to
tell us that there is construction yeah
and look at this here we
are 500 ft take left where's Oxford take
left atford
Avenue Costco is going to be on the left
yeah the Costco is going to be on the
left you probably got about another
maybe half
mile oh man there looks like a lot of
traffic
make a left on the Fuller that's our
home and in two blocks for
home one more block I think we got
this oh man really
are how does it feel to
lose like you guys got dead
last what ways did you take what way I
don't
know